>> MUCHNICK: Aviary is a company that creates
multimedia online editing software. Whether
you want do image editing, vector editing,
audio editing, or more right in your browser,
we provide the software to do it. Originally,
Aviary started with a company called worth1000.com
which is a competition site where artists
can compete in fun image editing contests.
And we created software to help serve the
needs of that community and realized it could
expand from there so that anyone can do image
editing online.
>> What is your extension about?
>> MUCHNICK: Aviary's Chrome extension allows
anyone to capture a screenshot of any web
page your are on, quickly and easily right
from within Chrome. You can then mark it up
using Aviary's editor--let say add arrows,
any kind of text mark up, and you can crop
it, rotate it around, do anything you want
with it, and then quickly share it with your
friends. We're hoping to extend the usefulness
of the extension, so that it can capture full
page content not just what's on the screen
natively. Additionally, we have a few other
plans to make it easier to edit images directly
off of any web page you're on.
>> How did you create the screenshot functionality
of your extension?
>> MUCHNICK: Our extension takes a screenshot
of the page and makes it editable on aviary.com.
To capture the screenshot, we use Chrome's
capture visible tab method. To make it available
to most of the Flash base Aviary tools, we
upload the image data to aviary.com via XML
HTTP request. For one of the tools, we create
a local conduit to make the image data directly
available to the Flash application without
uploading it to aviary.com at all.
>> What got you interested in Google Chrome
extensions?
>> MUCHNICK: What got us interested in Chrome
extensions was really how--first of all, how
quickly Chrome works and how smoothly all
of Aviary's tools operate on it. We've been
using Chrome since day one because it really
enables our development to go so smoothly.
We work with web pages all the time and we
really do a lot of screen capture and mark
up internally in our office. So for us to
now take that Chrome extension and provide
it to our user base was a no-brainer. And
additionally, if it encourages Aviary's users
to get a better experience because they're
using the Chrome browser, well that's a--that's
a huge win for us.
>> What was your experience developing Google
Chrome extensions?
>> MUCHNICK: Our experience developing Chrome
extensions was--was great, it was extremely
simple to develop and deploy. And we love
the fact that once you developed it, there's
no sandbox to hold you back. You simply put
it up on Google's website and it is immediately
updated and deployed for all your users. When
you're stuck in a sandbox it can really cripple
your development and rapid innovation. And
we're super happy that Google recognizes that.
>> How did your vision evolve as you were
working on your extension?
>> MUCHNICK: The product evolved the entire
time we were working on the extension. We
had to resign ourselves to the fact that certain
elements weren't necessarily complete in the
API. But we were able to find workarounds.
>> What were some challenges you faced when
writing your extension?
>> MUCHNICK: There were some issues that we
had to cope with when developing our extension
and I think we came up with some innovative
solutions. For example, trying to build out
a menu for--when someone clicks on that browser
action icon, we had to come up with that ourselves
and actually simulate a menu pop-up. Additionally,
we had two things; we really had to simulate
full page screen capture, so we came up with
a way of rolling down the page and taking
snapshots as we went using JavaScript and
then reassembling it. And lastly, we had to
do some filter clean up on some of the JPEG
full page screen capture.
>> What do you think about Google Chrome's
decision to use CSS, HTML, and JavaScript
as the basis of its extension framework?
>> MUCHNICK: We love Chrome's decision to
use HTML, JavaScript, and CSS in creating
extensions. It makes it so much simpler for
everyone on our development team to pick up
and run with. Additionally, it seems like
this method means the browser is free to operate
without additional bloat prior to the extension
being invoked.
>> How many times have you updated your extension?
>> MUCHNICK: We've updated our extension twice
so far and the experience was fantastic. Once
we figured out how to get the manifest correctly
uploaded it was a snap and it was instantly
deployed and available for our users.
>> How did you promote your extension?
>> MUCHNICK: To promote our extension we updated
our user base on our own blog and newsletter
and shared it with relevant tech blogs. We
also plan to promote it in context within
our existing product set.
>> What advice can you give someone before
starting to work on a Google Chrome extension?
>> MUCHNICK: If you're working on a Chrome
extension, consider the overall architecture
of your extension before you begin. Especially
how you will divide up responsibilities and
communicate between the background page, content
scripts, and more.
>> Come meet the Aviary Team at the Google
IO conference.